Let's talk not just about removing Donald
Trump, but removing a malignant Republicans
from the Senate as well.
One of the things I would love to see in November
of 2020 is a prominent Republican Senator
defeated.
Uh, we know that Senate majority leader, Mitch
McConnell has multiple challengers.
It's an uphill battle.
It's going to be a tough one, but it's one
worth fighting.
There's another interesting one, which is
South Carolina Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham, who's challenger.
Jamie Harrison raised more than three and
a half million dollars during the fourth quarter
of 2019.
This is more than listen to this.
He raised more than any South Carolina Democrat
has ever raised in a corridor in the history
of South Carolina.
He now has more than four point $6 million
on hand.
Normal caveats here are very often in red
States.
The democratic challengers are pretty centrist
establishment types.
Jamie Harrison is a centrist establishment
type.
He's a DNC official.
Former chairman of the South Carolina DNC
campaign is backed by the DSCC.
But this is still a good news because Lindsey
Graham has been one of the most vocal Trump
Brown nosers during the last 30 years.
Culminating maybe with this absolutely unhinged
rant a, did I say 30 years?
I met three years unhinged rant in support
of Donald Trump's often accused of sexual
assault Supreme court.
Pick Brett Kavanaugh.
Remember when, uh, Lindsey Graham appeared
to have a medical incident from how crazy
he went during those hearings.
Take a look at this.
If you wanted a FBI investigation, you could
have come to us.
What you want to do is destroy this guy's
life.
Hold this seat open and hope you win in 2020
you said that not me.
You've got nothing to apologize for.
When you see Sotomayer and Kagan tell him
that Lindsay said, Oh, cos I voted for them.
I would never do to them.
What you've done to this guy.
This is the most unethical sham since I've
been in politics.
And if you really wanted to know the truth,
you sure as hell wouldn't have done what you've
done to this guy.
Are you a gang rapist?
No.
Yeah, so it would be a great accomplishment
to knock out Lindsey Graham.
It is a huge uphill battle.
Back in 2014 in very red South Carolina, Lindsey
won by 17 points, 55 to 38 over a GRA.
A guy named Brad Hadow, but Jamie Harrison
is raising more money.
Lindsey Graham might have some liability hanging
on him because of his association with Trump.
We just don't know yet.
Jamie Harrison is a really long shot for sure,
but anything can happen in any race any year.
The polls aren't looking great at the, the
polling, we actually have no really good polling
in South Carolina.
We have a six month old pole, uh, from change
research where Lindsey was pulling 70% but
Jamie Harrison wasn't even in that pole.
And now Jamie Harrison has nearly $5 million
to spend.
So I don't think we can read too much into
the polling one way or the other.
Other to say, other than to say it will be
a tough one.
It's fun to dream.
But imagine if both Lindsey Graham and Mitch
McConnell were to lose their seats in the
same election cycle.
Unlikely.
But let's work every race like it's potentially
winnable.
The fact alone that candidates for historically
noncompetitive Senate seats like South Carolina
and Kentucky are even able to raise this much
money, tells us a lot.
It's also sort of frustrating that some candidates
in more competitive States like North Carolina
and Georgia are having trouble raising money.
That actually is, is not good.
But let's remember the lessons from the midterms
of 2018.
You know, when, when Democrats took over the
house in 2018, I remember that there was satisfaction
to some degree, but also kind of a feeling
of helplessness.
Like what can, what can we really do with
taking over the house?
Trump has executive orders, his cabinet, the
Senate.
Well, because Democrats took over the house
in 2018, Donald Trump has been impeached,
becoming only the third president in history
to be impeached.
Now that may go nowhere.
It may, uh, it certainly is not likely to
lead to Donald Trump's conviction in the Senate.
It may help to remove Donald Trump by voting
him out in November of 2020.
But this is why every single one of these
races has to be fought.
Every single one of these Senate races that
could be taken from a Republican has to be
fought.
We're only a few seats from a majority in
the Senate.
I've looked at the numbers.
I've told you it's tough.
2022 is more likely, but we won't.
Given that we're likely to lose one seat in
the Senate, we only need to pick up five in
order to take over control.
It is not impossible and we should be fighting
for it.
The 2018 midterms and Trump now being impeached
are exhibit a as to why this matters.